good afternoon everyone my name is bill
Weldon and I'm a PhD student at Cornell
University here as part of the Great
Lakes hop working group to give a deep
dive discussion on hot powdery mildew
disease identification and management so
just a little bit of personal background
my advisor is dr. David godori and we
are based out of Cornell Agrotech which
is in Geneva New York at the New York
State Agricultural Experiment Station
which is a research campus of Cornell
University my dissertation focus is on
population biology and epidemiology of
hot powdery mildew which has a larger
overall theme of applied management of
hot powdery mildew before I dive right
into talking only about powdery mildew I
think it's crucial to talk about why you
really need to know the differences in
identification between downy and powdery
mildew and why that is so important it's
the the two organisms responsible for
downy mildew and powdery mildew belong
to completely different kingdoms on the
evolutionary tree and so we have a
simple evolutionary tree here on the
right and you can see plants on one
branch you have animals on another
branch
yeah bacteria down here very early on
the evolutionary tree which makes sense
but the two branches that I want to
focus on our fungi and this branch over
here that's called all my seeds and the
reason I want to focus on those two is
because the organism that causes hot
powdery mildew belongs to this branch
fungi it is a fungus however the
organism that causes hop downy mildew it
is often called and referred to as a
fungus but it is not truly a fungus it
is not on this branch is actually on the
branch of o-mai seeds
and so they are very distantly related
just like plants and animals are
distantly related and you can liken this
to them both being natural disasters
they're both capable of causing large
amounts of destruction within the hop
yard but one being a fire and one being
a tornado you would respond to these two
in completely different ways and in fact
the way that you'd respond to a fire in
your house by leaving your house
be the worst move that you could ever
make in in the actual reality of a
tornado
he'd probably get swept away by the
tornado if that was actually the case
well this relates kind of back to Danny
mildew and powdery mildew because they
generally require different fungicides
for good specific control so they are
fire and tornado in relation to what
fungicides they require in order to
control these two pathogens most modern
fungicides designed to control powdery
mildew do little to nothing to manage
downy mildew and vice versa so it is
crucial that when you're identifying
which disease is out in your yard that
you're confident in making that
diagnosis so that then you can move
forward and appropriately choose what
disease management strategies and
chemicals you to you choose to control
the problem okay so now we can focus on
exclusively powdery mildew for the rest
of our time so I'm going to cover some
background on the disease move into some
identification strategies quick comment
on varietal resistance and then focus on
management practices through scouting
some cultural practices and then
management through use of fungicides so
a bit of background on how powdery
mildew like I said it's caused by a
fungus photosphere macular and this is
data out of Pacific Northwest that
growers spend about seven hundred and
forty dollars per hectare oh and
chemical control and get about a fifteen
percent annual you loss still due to
damage caused by powdery mildew it's
important to note that this organism is
an obligate bio troph and this means
that this pathogen needs living hop
tissue in order to be able to grow so it
can't grow in the soil like some fungi
it can't grow on bark it can't grow on
other plants that needs living hot
tissue specifically it is directly and
intimately tied to hop tissue in order
to grow like many of us know the reason
that we care about hot powdery mildew is
because of the damage that it directly
does to hop cones so it causes stunting
browning and distortion of the alpha and
beta acid profiles of hop cones which
results in rejection for you
the brewing process so the pathogen can
overwinter in one of two ways they can
overwinter asexually or it can
overwinter through a sexual process the
asexual process so a sexual infection of
dormant hot buds is what we commonly
associate them with the pathogens this
is the white fluffy mycelial growth of
the fungus that is the namesake for hot
powdery mildew and when this growth
extends down on to the hot buds that
either go dormant or semi dormant just
below the soil line at a very very low
rate of less than 1% those buds will
emerge the following spring having
survived the stresses of the winter and
they will emerge also infected with the
powdery mildew pathogen and so we see
this here on the right the shoots are
termed flag shoots when they are
infected with hot powdery mildew and
they're called that because they stick
out like a flag in comparison to all of
the other green leave tissue that's
surrounding it like I said this happens
at a very low rate which is good from an
initial disease pressure standpoint but
it also means that you need to be
scouting visually vigilantly in order to
do a good job of finding these out in
your yard and removing them before they
spread the disease too much and get
disease going this picture is to
demonstrate that this flag shoot here
was pretty cryptically kind of hidden
within some of the basal foliage of
surrounding otherwise healthy looking
hop tissue and sometimes flag shoots can
be buried within these microclimates
where they're protected by other hop
leaves and they're in this nice shaded
kind of cool climate which is optimal
for powdery mildew growth
and so when you're scouting you need to
be vigilantly scouting not only on the
surface but actually be digging within
some of the basal voyage to see if
there's any flag shoots that have
emerged that you can't see just on a
pass by the other way that the pathogen
can overwinter is through a sexual
reproduction process where it produces
these overwintering structures called
kazna these--oh
and kind of interestingly like mammals
this fungal species has two mating types
it has two genders essentially and so
when spores of both genders land on the
same leaf and grow in their typical
white fluffy form of asexual growth if
those two growing fronts overlap
wherever they overlap they will
recognize one another and initiate
sexual reproduction of this
overwintering structure and so this leaf
here on the left instead of seeing lots
and lots of white powdery growth we're
seeing these brown casma theseus
structures and each one of these little
black specks is an individual casma
theseus there can be thousands on one
leaf under the microscope what they
actually look like is they're like
shells they're like cases that on the
inside how is a sac that is protecting
spores that when this casma theseö the
brown structure cracks open in the
spring it releases the spores and should
these spores land on any surrounding
susceptible hot issue would permeate the
disease into the following season it has
thought that casma theseus an
overwintering source are much more
efficient than the asexual kind of white
growth that happens on dormant buds that
produces flag shoots but it's not known
to what degree they are better but it's
also important to note that through all
of kind of the population analysis and
scouting that we've done in the Pacific
Northwest and in the Midwest and the
eastern US for the vast majority of
commercial yards there's only one mating
type that we've found in the majority of
those yards and so those growers don't
necessarily need to be modifying their
disease management program in response
to this sexual structure because it's
it's not forming in their yards they
only have one gender in their yard and
so they this this structure can't form
and so it's important to be scouting for
it it's important to be on the lookout
for it but you know you don't need to
make any modifications
occasions to your disease management
program until you know it's in your yard
and you could you would you would see
that in the fall and make modifications
and know that you have kind of a higher
initial disease pressure going into that
following spring so now getting into
some proper identification so what to
physically look for in the yard early in
the spring the first thing that you're
going to look for obviously are the flag
shoots and so these emerge in your first
and your second waves of buds that break
ground and they can emerge potentially
infected at a very low rate and because
it happens at a very low rate you need
to make sure that you're vigilant and
scouting for these because this is your
first effort at removing that initial
source of inoculum within your hop yard
for the rest of the growing season what
you're on the lookout for is just the
typical white powdery growth that could
be happening on any green tissue on your
hop plants so under the microscope they
the spores of powdery mildew actually
look like kind of transparent
non-pigmented little beads that are
stacked up in Chains as such but to the
naked eye when you look at them kind of
macroscopically it looks like this white
fluffy powdery growth so where on the
plant can the disease be found
powdery mildew can be found growing on
all green plant tissue and this includes
both sides of the leaves young hot stems
and shoots on the hop cones obviously
and the reason I underlined both sides
of the leaves is because that is in
stark contrast to downy mildew in which
the spores of the downy mildew pathogen
can only be produced on the underside of
hop leaves and so if you're doing any
sort of scouting and you see spore
production on the top side of the leaf
surface as in this picture here that's a
strong indicator that if you're
considering powdery versus downing this
would make you lean towards powdery
mildew being being what you're dealing
with it's important to note that powdery
mildew cannot cause systemic infection
that risks killing the hop chrome-like
is the case for hop down e mildew but it
still can permeate on the dormant buds
as we previously talked about
one additional factor that can help you
just get in the right mindset for
knowing which disease is likely to be a
new yard is to know the optimal
conditions for powdery mildew and also
dam you'll do as a comparison
so typically seasons favor high
prevalence of one disease over the other
so in the case of powdery mildew these
seasons are favored powdery mildews
favored during seasons of temperate
drier conditions the pathogen these
those little speed like spores they
don't require water to be able to grow
and in fact so theoretically every day
is a potential infection period but
because those spores are clear they're
not pigmented and so UV light from sun
exposure can be damaging to them and so
that can be a limiting factor in where
they can grow downy mildew just for
comparison it's strongly favored by wet
rainy seasons the the spores that downy
mildew produces actually do require
water in order to be able to infect and
so seasons of rain and high humidity
among due periods those are the seasons
where you would lean toward suspecting
downy mildew being the problem more so
than powdering one quick comment about
varietal resistance this is a PDF that
is available on the cornell ops web page
and this is a table from one of our
documents that we have available online
and it's just showing kind of the most
up-to-date knowledge on varieties
resistant to powdery mildew in the US
some varieties that have received
recently lost resistance so the nugget
variety in the Pacific Northwest there's
a strain of powdery mildew that's
overcome that resistance and also
strains of powdery mildew that are
adapted to grow on cascade which was a
previously resistant Friday so getting
into management practices for powdery
mildew so the first line of defense is
always to choose resistant varieties
when possible I know that breweries and
brewery demand has a large fact plays a
large role in which varieties get
planted and so at least understanding
the general level of susceptibility to
powdery mildew when it's not possible
just choose a resistant bright
is is crucial as well this is especially
important for organic production and
knowing kind of the the resistance
profile of the varieties that are
planted in your yard will guide your
scouting intensity as well as your spray
program intensity right off the bat as
you start your yard and going into the
season in terms of scouting you should
Scout as soon as the shoots emerge and
scout as often as possible as often as
can be handled by your operation the
most critical scouting periods for
powdery mildew are at shoot emergence
because this is when you're looking for
the flag shoots at shoot training
because this is when you're choosing
kind of your three or four best shoots
just string and you should be looking in
the basal foliage surrounding that to
see if there's any powdery mildew that
might creep start to creep up the
trellis and your most critical time is
one week prior to bloom through four
weeks post bloom because those are when
your juvenile hop cones the the burs are
most susceptible to powdery mildew so a
general scouting approach when disease
pressure is low is to scout about 100 to
200 plants or Hills evenly dispersed
among varieties and throughout your yard
pay special attention to the basal
foliage as well as any young still
developing cop comes and leaves you're
looking for white powdery colonies on
any of these tissues and should you
suspect powdery mildew in any case you
can remove the question will shoot place
it inside of a ziplock bag with a
slightly damp paper towel to kind of
keep the humidity up stored at room
temperature in a spot that gets a daily
light dark cycle and then check for
production of spores one one one day and
two days later and that would be a wait
there's a powdery mildew present there
you're gonna start to see production of
spores you'll see sporulation so some of
the cultural practices that you can do
this these cultural practices are the
legwork to make your fungicides work
better they're to take pressure off of
your fungicides being kind of the last
line of defense and kind of take
stress off your fungicides and so these
are these are things that you should
always be doing each season one of them
pruning so this is the act of cutting
back the first wave of growth and you
shouldn't do this here first or probably
your second year of production but once
your varieties start to get a little bit
more vigorous in their growth you cut
back that first wave of shoots that
emerge from the ground and this cuts
away any potentially infected hot
material that is emerging and parading
powdery mildew or downy mildew or any
other possible diseases the frequency
and the intensity of your pruning as
dependent upon the age of your yard and
also the vigor of your varieties how
bigger ously each of your varieties is
growing generally mechanical pruning is
more effective but there's also just the
fact that any pruning is better than no
pruning in terms of training times it is
best to try and get your shoots out of
that basil foliage as soon as possible I
know that there are their timing
considerations in terms of reaching the
top of the trellis to produce production
of lateral branches but the sooner you
can get your primary kind of most
optimal shoots up and trained away from
all the basal foliage the sooner they'll
be away from kind of that micro climate
where powdery mildew and downy mildew
are likely to kind of rear their heads
the last kind of cultural practice to
consider is stripping the lower leaves
so this is breaking the green bridge and
so this picture here you can see this
green bridge of green hops shoots and
leaves that if there was any sort of
disease going on along the ground here
this would be an easy Highway for the
pathogen to spread up these two adjacent
plants and so again you probably
wouldn't want to do this the first
couple years of your yard but once your
plants are growing vigorously and once
they reach a certain height so about ten
feet you could strip off the lower three
feet of growth and this breaks that
green bridge and also
induces some airflow along the soil line
which removes that micro high humidity
microclimate associated with kind of a
basal foliage so the last thing to
comment on is fungicides in terms of
management and so it's important to know
your fungicides know which fungicides
apply to downy mildew versus powdery
mildew and check the label if you're
unsure there are many applications
students to make you on the label and
you want to save your big guns for your
most critical management periods
especially that time around bloom so
these are fungicides that are generally
specific to powdery mildew I won't go
into them into detail but they're here
as examples and as a resource free to
use again these are examples the product
should always be used according to the
label in a given state and you should
make contact with your Cooperative
Extension personnel or your regional
personnel and make sure that each
product is labeled for hops so these
next few slides are credit to Dave Jen
out of Oregon State and this is another
just resource that I wanted to include
in the PowerPoint deck as more examples
of fungicides that are available for use
but again check whether they're
available and legal to use in your area
so this slide here again provided by
Dave is intended to show that really
under high disease pressure high
pressure of powdery mildew is when you
start to see a discrepancy in how your
fungicides perform but if you can keep
your disease pressure your powdery
mildew pressure moderate to low which is
done through kind of being very good
about your cultural practices all of
your fungicides perform quite well in
comparison till the untreated and so
this is really what you're aiming for is
to be good about your cultural practices
and keep it under this moderate pressure
so that you don't need to be relying
quite as heavily on fungicides to be the
factor that is keeping your percent cone
infection at a satisfactory level
this slide here is also from Dave and it
is here as a resource and is intended to
provide some context in terms of timing
of fungicide applications the important
things to note here are that some of our
bigger guns such as the ovando or Quinn
Tech or Luna and pristine they're all
around flowering and they're they're
used at that time to protect the hop
cones as much as possible because that
is the direct harvestable product that
we're trying to protect
and so you time them around at that time
and so with that I want to thank you all
for your time I have my contact
information listed here feel free to
email me with any follow-up questions
that you may have and I will be happy to
get in touch with you thank you very
much